Colonia española primero y
estadounidense después, Puerto Rico, una
pequeña isla del caribe, se configura
hoy como un estado libre asociado a los
Estados Unidos donde sus ciudadanos
cuentan con la nacionalidad
estadounidense pero salvo que trasladen
su residencia a otro estado no pueden
votar en las elecciones presidenciales y,
aunque tienen un representante en el
congreso, esté carece también de
voto.
Todas las grandes cuestiones ya sean
políticas, económicas o militares
quedan bajo la jurisdicción federal de
los Estados Unidos.
Últimamente se habla mucho de este
territorio y es que hace aproximadamente
un año
el gobernador de Puerto Rico Alejandro
García-Padilla anunciaba que la isla no
sería capaz de hacer frente a sus
compromisos financieros
esto es a devolver la abultada deuda
contraída. Tras casi diez años de
depresión Puerto Rico incurría en "default".
Y este año, lejos de haber subsanado el
problema, entre mayo y julio la isla va a
suspender pagos en un importe cercano a
los 3.000 millones de dólares-
Puerto Rico también conocido como la
Grecia del Caribe es hoy insolvente.
Su deuda pública supera los 72 mil
millones de dólares para una población
de apenas tres millones y medio de
personas y si tenemos en cuenta a las
empresas públicas la deuda superaría
con creces el 100% del pib
Últimamente se
está discutiendo mucho acerca de cómo
solucionar la grave crisis en la que se
encuentra Puerto Rico
"crisis in Puerto Rico"
"I went to Puerto Rico"
"Puerto Rico"
"el estado libre asociado de Puerto Rico"
Se está hablando de cambios en el
régimen jurídico político de una
posible declaración de bancarrota
e incluso de un rescate, ahora bien la
pregunta que tenemos que hacernos es: cómo hemos
llegado a este punto. Bien, hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a mirar hacia atrás
hoy sí vamos a mirar por el retrovisor
para tratar de descubrir las causas que
han llevado a Puerto Rico a la quiebra
así pues, ¿qué es lo que ha ocurrido? Bien
aunque el gran culpable sin dudas el
gobierno portorriqueño que ha gastado
salvajemente y ha despreciado la
importancia que en el tejido económico
tienen los conceptos de empresa,
negocios y en cierto modo seguridad
jurídica
Hoy vamos a ver cómo Washington tiene
una porción de responsabilidad tan
grande que prácticamente podemos afirmar que los Estados Unidos han quebrado
Puerto Rico y es que la gran potencia
americana ha bombardeado a esta isla con
5 políticas de resultados devastadores.
Cinco políticas en materia de impuestos,
en materia de comercio de regulaciones,
salarios y asistencia social
Con la supuesta intención de ayudar a
la economía de Puerto Rico y favorecer
que su gobierno pudiera acceder a los
mercados de capitales al albor de la ley
Jones-Shafroth, Washington fijó una triple
sanción municipal estatal y federal
sobre los intereses de la deuda pública
de Puerto Rico.
Así si cualquier ciudadano americano
compraba duda pública de Puerto Rico
quedaba exento de pagar impuestos sobre
los intereses recibidos o dicho de otra
manera si un ciudadano americano compraba de
una de una empresa tenía que pagar
impuestos pero sí en cambio se la
compraba a los políticos
portorriqueños no tenía que pagar
absolutamente nada.
Ya os podéis imaginar que en unas
condiciones tan atractivas no fue
extraño que se formasen colas para
prestarle dinero al gobierno de la isla.
Dinero fácil para comprar votos
esto es: ¿qué mejor escenario podemos
imaginar para políticos irresponsables?
Contra toda
lógica
mientras el gobierno federal alentaba
que el gobierno de Puerto Rico se
endeudara cada vez más y más se lo
ponía más difícil a la economía
privada.
Así finalmente en 2006 se suprimió la
llamada sección 936 del código fiscal
que incluye importantes beneficios para
aquellas empresas que invirtiesen en la
isla. Era un modelo que me había tenido mucho
éxito y es que los años precedentes
habían conseguido que Puerto Rico creciese
muchísimo y llegase a convertirse en un
incipiente potencia manufacturera y
farmacéutica. Bien, no es extraño que una
vez terminados estos incentivos en el año
2006, dos años antes de la gran crisis
financiera, Puerto Rico comenzase su
particular caída al abismo.
Tal vez el punto más controvertido y la
ley más absurda. La Ley Jones aprobada
en 1920 y aún hoy en día en vigor prohíbe que barcos con bandera extranjera
puedan transportar mercancías entre dos
puertos de los Estados Unidos. Así,
siguiendo esta ley un barco procedente
de China cargado de contenedores no
puede detenerse en Puerto Rico, tiene que
continuar hasta tierra continental,
descargar sus contenedores, los cuales
tienen que volver a ser cargados en otro
barco esta vez sí con bandera y
tripulación estadounidense lo que
evidentemente es muchísimo más caro y
llevados de vuelta a Puerto Rico.
El resultado de todo esto es que Puerto
Rico tiene los costes de envío más caros
de todos los países del Caribe algo que
no sólo dificulta el comercio sino que
encarece también las exportaciones y
reduce el poder adquisitivo de todos los
puertorriqueños.
De hecho para hacernos una idea de la
implicación de esta ley absurda
cabe decir que puerto rico que tiene una
renta media aproximadamente la mitad que el
estado de Mississippi -el más pobre de los
Estados Unidos continental- tiene un
costo de vida superior a la media
estatal
El salario mínimo en Puerto Rico es el
salario mínimo federal es decir 7,25 $/hora
Lo que ocurre es que cómo hemos visto
tanto el nivel de desarrollo como la
renta media de Puerto Rico es muy
inferior a la del resto de estados de
los Estados Unidos con lo que el efecto
distorsionador de esta política es enorme.
El salario mínimo fijado que, por cierto, es más alto que el que tenemos en España
equivale al 77% del
salario medio portorriqueño, es decir,
del salario medio de todas las
profesiones y trabajos de la isla,
lo que ha conducido a que tan sólo una
de cada tres personas en edad de
trabajar lo hagan. Por cierto, cabe decir
que de estas personas una de cada cuatro
lo hacen para la administración pública con
lo que podemos llegar a la conclusión
de que menos del 25% de la población de
Puerto Rico trabaja en la economía
productiva
"Esto era una concurrida zona
comercial hace dos años y así es
como está hoy en día"
Por otra parte, la regulación federal
implica también un nivel anormalmente
alto de prestaciones sociales para lo
que son los parámetros de Puerto Rico,
de hecho hay estudios que demuestran que
a muchas familias les es conveniente recibir
ayudas sociales antes que trabajar, en
tanto en cuanto los ingresos a los que
van a poder acceder son sustancialmente
mayores.
Todo esto no sólo ha derivado en una gran
crisis económica sino también en un
auténtico éxodo de población sobre
todo de su población más joven y más
preparada hacia los Estados Unidos
continentales
"La salida masiva de
puertorriqueños y puertorriqueñas
sobre todo a estados unidos es la
muestra más elocuente del
fracaso del modelo económico social del
estado libre asociado.
Así desde el año 2006 cuando comienza
la crisis en Puerto Rico se inicia un
proceso que ha diezmado considerablemente la fuerza laboral y productiva
de la isla y es que a la postre los
portorriqueños tienen la ciudadanía
estadounidense y ante una situación de
adversidad les compensa hacer las
maletas y mudarse a los Estados Unidos
continentales. 84.000 sólo en el pasado
año y hoy había más puertorriqueños
en Estados Unidos continental que en el
mismo Puerto Rico.
Bueno espero que os haya gustado este
vídeo y también por supuesto espero
vuestros comentarios para poder abrir
debate
un saludo y hasta la próxima